well Andrew Tate joins me again now
Andrew good to see you salam alaikum
peers good to see you I I've genuinely
been Amazed by the reaction I've had in
the streets not just here but I went to
Qatar for the World Cup had the same
thing there a lot of people coming up
about because John Ronaldo obviously but
also a lot of people coming up about you
and they were almost exclusively men
young men who genuinely see you as a
role model as somebody who inspires them
as somebody they want to be like yeah so
it made me think the first interview you
had was quite combative the second time
a short interview less so I want to try
and work out in this one who you are
because it struck me as extraordinary
that Google this week revealed some
stats for the year the number one person
whose name followed people Google
searching who is in 2022 was Andrew Tate
yeah that's quite remarkable I think
there's a whole swath of the population
especially young men that feel
disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says to things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a basking
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution
where perhaps you've done unsaid stuff
you shouldn't have done and as you get
older perhaps as you get bigger more
followed around the world you sense a
responsibility perhaps you didn't have
early on well we all evolve every human
evolves day by day you wouldn't be human
if you didn't evolve on an hour-by-hour
basis but I do not think I'm a Force for
good I absolutely not really know I am a
Force for good because I'm a force for
truth and truth is a good thing without
truth we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there I feel like we're starting
to combat it my cancellation was the
beginning of a change in public
Consciousness Elon having Twitter is
another beginning of the change in
public Consciousness and anybody who
stands up and speaks what they truly
believe even if it's something I don't
personally agree with I think that truth
is absolutely important and people's
personal truths and people's personal
opinions even on differing sides of the
same opinion should be heard
tell me about your life you were born to
a mixed race uh couple your father was
an African-American a chess player yeah
uh and your mother she was from this
country correct yeah so my father was
was black chess player he was in the Air
Force he met my mother here in England
and then I was raised initially in the
United States and then I moved to Luton
England when I was younger so I've moved
around a lot I've lived uh eclectic life
in many different scenarios we've moved
around I've done a lot of different
things learned a lot of different
experiences and uh I mean would you
identify I consider myself British now
but I will say that part of me the
Patriotic Britain side of me is
devastated by the state of the UK
currently and I want to make that very
clear the Patriotic Britain me truly
loves this country and seeing what's
happening to it especially to our major
cities is almost heartbreaking to watch
in real time in what way it's falling
apart this is a failed Society by every
metric you can possibly measure it is
absolutely not really failing the cost
of living crisis the crime rates
everything is falling apart if you
compare it to a country tree like the
United Arab Emirates you compare it to a
city like Dubai London which should be
the greatest city on earth is failing in
absolutely every metric because our
leadership is a joke if you look at
Dubai in the UAE the leadership there is
so Flawless so genuinely genius they saw
ahead and have built almost a Utopia and
then you look at London you came and
walk around with a watch on it's
disgusting you know it's very
interesting I was in Qatar for the World
Cup obviously a lot of people in England
taking a very sensorious moral view
about the World Cup being in the Middle
East at all because of their laws
against homosexuality because of their
treatment of Migrant workers I've got to
say not that I don't share the concerns
about those things of course I do but I
found a lot of The Virtue signaling and
I think that's what it was in many cases
about the whole region actually quite
distasteful because when I was in Qatar
a I thought the World Cup was
fantastically well run an incredibly
good experience but a lot of qataris
were saying to me you know there's this
weird quaint feeling back in your
country that we'll want to Aspire to
behave like that that we all want to
live in a country with massive drug
problems with massive knife crime issues
with scenes like the European
championships final where it's complete
lawlessness going on where
stuff like the NHS the system of
healthcare is basically collapsing where
the education system is dropping behind
so on and so on and so on it's a really
interesting perspective they were like I
know you all think that we want to have
your form of democracy in your form of
life but actually we're fine thanks
absolutely because it's a failed society
and it's Godless I think it's disgusting
we leave our old people to rot in old
people's homes and then we sit there and
say we don't have enough money for
nurses I understand this nurse strike
very well on how frustrating it can be
if you walk into a hospital and the
nurse is not prepared to work but the
nurses would be prepared to work at the
current wage if they believe this
country was spending its money prudently
when you see this country spending its
money and just absolutely wasting it
pulling out of thin air to fund proxy
wars God knows where that has nothing to
do with them of course as a nurse you're
going to stand up and say well can I get
a pay rise this country has failed on
every metric and especially our major
cities I've just come to London now I
made it very clear to my private jet
pilot I said fuel the Jet and leave it
running because the second finished
talking appears I'm leaving this cesspit
it's disgusting this country and London
as a whole 10 years ago was the one of
the most hospitable cities on Earth now
you cannot walk around safely with a
watch on
because self-belief is important I do
believe myself but this has not gone
well you're quite good at chess I'll
give you that yeah well in the chess
board of life I've done pretty good
I've done okay
check the question is can you beat me in
time you've only got 50 seconds check
that's interesting yeah I don't think
you can let's see uh
easy
uh mate in two piers
yeah you can have that doesn't matter
it's mating two check
good game sir well played thank you 25
seconds away from safety
okay well as you say I'll give you
something uh you get a chess thank you
you have to be you just beat me
I know you're a nationally
internationally related what does chess
talk to you about life quickly I can
teach you a lot of things like I said
about the queen being able to run around
the board the king having to move a
square at a time about the fact you need
to think ahead absolutely everything is
your fault but there is a saying which
is actually one of my favorite sayings
in the world that said a well-gamed a
well-played game of chess is a sign of a
gentleman but an expertly game expertly
played game of chesses to sign up a
wasted life he's not your idea of a role
model well no he's not I I see him as a
symptom of a problem rather than a
solution to it I can understand what's
the problem that he's the symptom the
problem is that I think a lot of young
men uh feel that nobody is speaking up
for them in their culture where we are
encouraged to have identity Politics the
only identity that isn't a good identity
is a young man or a young white male he
talks in a very straight way and he
gives straight answers to uh some
questions which I think he gives very
wrong answers to
um but I find him repellent I think he
he talks about he talks he basically
creates Straw Men that he destroys so he
will uh depict feminism as a particular
kind of thing a kind of man-hating thing
which it isn't well it is for some
feminist for a small number of families
I mean there are some radical feminism
definitely are there definitely are but
most people know that feminism is about
just thinking that everyone should have
equal opportunities regardless of yeah
and once he's using that to kind of
attack the more extreme forms of
feminism which that says you know women
can do anything and mine can do and he
was using that as an example but I do
think you know you lose people when you
refuse to outright condemn sort of 10th
Century barbarians like this um but I I
don't think when you said it has nothing
to do with them I think he's not willing
to get into dicey territory in that way
but it's like you speak in such absolute
terms why do you think he's a misogynist
I don't think he's a misogynist no I
don't think massages means somebody who
hates women I just think he hates women
I think he thinks women are nothing I
think he would not know what to do with
you and I Esther because he does not
know how to deal he gives interviews to
people like you or to Hugo Rifkin he'll
give interviews a lot of women I've
spoken to about it but other women he's
done interviews with women I've seen
them for
yeah women do a lot of women do like him
exactly there are a lot of women who
don't know him who seem to hate him
ironically um but I'm not sure this is
clear he's a misogynist I don't think
he's a misogynist and I have a brother
who's probably within his Target
demographic 23 and I can understand why
his message would resonate with him
because
it's normal exactly for young men to
feel like they don't have a place in
Western society and he actually made
that point I just think when you don't
want to outright condemn 10th Century
barbarians like the Taliban you tend to
lose your case with more moderate people
but again well not his Target or the
fact that his his understanding about
what's happening in Afghanistan is that
it's a feminist issue rather than a
human I don't think he said that well no
he did he said send this feminist in
it's a human issue where we made all
these promises to people in Afghanistan
and then we left well let's be clear we
betrayed those words we absolutely
in the way we pulled out of Afghanistan
overnight and we betrayed not only
people who work with us the interpreters
and so on but people are millions
millions of Afghan women yeah I've just
been tossed back to these barriers well
Harry and Megan have demanded a royal
apology for the claims made in their
Netflix documentary The six-hour
wineathon launched blistering attacks on
Britain and the British Monarchy and the
palace is reportedly baffled by the
request they're not the only ones and as
if we haven't suffered enough tonight
Netflix released a new trailer for
another Harry and Megan show this one
promises to be just as smug as the first
one
every time I think they can't plummet
new depths these two they're now
comparing themselves to Nelson Mandela
who spent nearly 30 years in a six by
six prison cell
really it went on to become the first
black president for South Africa a
unifying leader of true greatness
one of the well actually the the most
impressive person I've ever interviewed
in my life they are comparing their dash
for freedom to a mansion in California
where they now Hawk out their Royal
titles for hundreds of millions of
dollars
that's what Mandela did in their eyes
well to me it's unbelievable but maybe
there are some out there that believe
this stuff
joining me now is the author and active
is Natalie Collins the former head of
Royal protection guy Davis and talk to
the contributor Esther cracker well let
me start the U.S do you be waiting
patiently here
um they're the new Mandela yeah I just
find it the arrogance is incredible to
demand an apology because that's how you
get an apology by demanding one a
sincere and honest and open apology I I
just think you know they officially
declared war on the royal family by
coming out with this Netflix documentary
they made it clear that they wanted no
reconciliation because you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't put your family
through that if you really wanted right
open genuine conversation and
Reconciliation also they just called
Prince Charles A a lying bully yeah
they've called Prince William even worse
even worse so they drove him out of the
country uh with his or he drove them out
of the country with his bullying and
lies they've called the whole family a
bunch of races I would even one apology
from someone's people like that that are
so negative in your view well I think I
can understand why they're demanding
apology because they're so
self-righteous about everything they
assume they're right of everything I
can't understand what earth makes them
think Charles and William would even
consider being in the room with them
right now but I do think there's an
element of the longer that they can keep
this Feud going that's more money in
their bank account because now
everything they do they'll be oh what
about William how's your relationship
with the royal family how's your
relationship with your father and so
that's that's basically you know a giant
check that they've blank checked how
could you trust them not to just
basically record everything that goes on
if they did have a meeting like that let
me go to Natalie Collins Natalie I'm
aware there are people out there that
completely disagree and think that they
are true Freedom Fighters who were
oppressed by the royal family and have
taken their oppression now to this vast
mansion in Montecito and Santa Barbara
it's a beautiful place I've been down to
that area lovely rolling ocean waves
beautiful lifestyle um not my idea of
what oppression looks like but there we
are each to their own
um but let's get to this idea of an
apology that you can basically call a
family a bunch of callus racists who
refuse to let you get help for suicidal
thoughts that you said you you said you
had that uh made racist comments
apparently that were so demeaning you
had to allude to them on an Oprah
Winfrey interview uh you now call him a
bunch of lying bullies including the new
king why would you expect anybody to sit
down with you and apologize after you've
done all the public trashing
I think in the context of a column that
was written today by Jeremy Clarkson
which uh described Meghan Markle as
worse than Rose Weston and calling on
people to have her stripped naked and
throw excrement on her in the street I
think it's really important that we put
the context of and what Megan and Harry
are talking about in the context of The
Wider hatred which to be fair you were a
real Pioneer in that hatred of Meghan
Markle years ago I don't hate Meghan
Markle I don't know hang on hang on hang
on
you said I hate Meghan Markle let me be
clear I've never said I hate Meghan
Markle I don't hate Meghan Markle I hate
what she's done to the royal family and
to the monarchy and to the reputation of
Britain only tonight the New York Times
has carried a major op-ed piece
absolutely trashing this country as a
racist country with a racist institution
at the head of IT a callous institution
that should be dismantled so yeah I see
real damage in what Meghan Markle and
Harry have both done now to the
reputation of his country and to our
monarchy so yeah but I don't hate them
individually as people and if you know
in relation to the Clarkson column which
he's now issued a mere culpa over I
didn't think he should have uh put that
in the column for for my personal view
but he's now said he wishes he hadn't
either so you know I don't see what that
has to do with the wider picture of
these two trashing their families and
they're demanding an apology
well I think in the same way that you're
saying you don't personally hate them
but you are opposed to what they stand
for and what they're saying and how
they've behaved I think that's entirely
the same argument that um Megan and
Harry are making in their in their
documentary and in the work that they've
they've done is saying that actually the
way that they've been harmed by this
institution by this system which you
know we cannot deny the impact of
colonialism we can't deny the impact of
this um monarchy in terms of we have a
history in this country of doing really
terrible things for the places and to
deny that reality to deny the impact and
and the really this this month this
monarchy how is it that in this day and
age we have a group of people who were
born into wealth and privilege just
because of being born into it it is
absolutely they're also responsible for
developing the economy that's the norm
they're also responsible for developing
the Commonwealth which has been one of
the great success stories in the world
and of course it's not really
Commonwealth though is it the people
who've got that wealth are mainly in uh
the royal family have a lot more
if you hate people who've got lots of
money without actually earning or
deserving it you must also hate
therefore the sussexes who've done
nothing to deserve it other than trash
their family I just I
I think you know I I I think there's a
sense that of course people we we can't
like hate people because of their
privileged but they're what they're
doing with it or how they use a lot
utilizing it is really important as well
and I think there is a sense that we are
also talking about a a man who as a boy
his mother was killed by obeying mob in
the media and then was true I'm sorry
I'm sorry again
these are easy lies to say on television
but I'm afraid I have to hold you to a
counter it's not a lie that is not
killed by a Baby Alive princess Diner
was killed by a drunk driver that was
the official inquest report into her
death it was a drunk driver speeding who
killed Princess Diana so it wasn't yeah
you might want it to be a bang mob and
maybe Harry has grown up thinking it was
a bae mob I could tell a hundred stories
about the way his mother colluded with
me as a newspaper editor with the
paparazzi or colluded with me over
having a private lunch at Kensington
Palace giving me loads of stories which
she knew I would then have as informed
information for my newspaper I could
tell the time that Diana rang me up and
gave me an hour-long interview about a
visit to a clinic she'd done uh signed
off on every page of the interview which
was faxed to her in return with her
initials on it and the next day said she
was outraged by the intrusive story in
the Daily Mirror which was the story she
given me at length over an hour on tape
so there are lots of different ways you
can skin this cat about the relationship
between the royal family and the media
my argument about about Megan and Harry
is they apparently were so disgusted by
this callous racist family and
institution that they fled the country
gave up Royal Duty now live in
California in extreme luxury and yet
bizarrely they still want to retain the
titles afforded them by the institution
they describe as callous races and